You guys got tattoos together.
We did.
Yeah.
Yeah. She's my queen. I don't know if you can see it.
Yeah. It's very, you got a very faint tattoo.
Which I think was, you know,
you didn't want it to really show up, right?
No, I was, I told my mom, I was like,
I'm gonna get a tattoo, she was like,
"Don't put it anywhere I can see it."
And I was like, "I'm getting it on my forearm."
Um, and so we kind of compromised and I got it in peach.
But it's the date
Peach. You got a peach colored tattoo.
Who gets a peach tattoo?
That's the exact color I would get.
I would get a peach tattoo.
(laughter)
It would just look like more freckles.
That's what I would do.
Me too, me too. Ginger problems, right?
Yes, ginger problems.
(laughter)
Um, but it's the date we both got Game of Thrones on.
Oh, that's nice.
Yeah its..
So you both got the same tattoo.
I can see nothing, there is absolutely nothing.
Yeah you can't see anything.
You know what I think?
I think that tattoo artist just lied to you.
It's somewhere on there!
Oh yeah, it's there. It's in a very faint peach.
I don't see anything.